[Music]
hello and welcome to be Ragan job
where's that participated with your John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where two brothers Hank and John
Green we answer you questions kidding
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but we're recording this one a
week early said we don't actually know
what the news is but we'll figure
something out John how you doing I'm
doing well
since we're recording this a week early
I'm pretty sure that by the time it's
announced our tour will have been
announced I have a new book coming out
Hank I don't know if you've heard about
it
yeah it's called Turtles all the way
down it comes out October 10th and Hank
and I are going on tour starting October
10th I'm not a hundred percent sure that
I'm allowed to be talking about this but
I'm gonna talk about in anyway in the
hopes of forcing penguins hands yeah
yeah so I just want to let everybody
know that you can I don't really know
where the website is that you can go to
go to probably sign to turtles calm and
I'm sure that'll take you to the tour
website I'm not totally positive how
this is all going to go down but I am
gonna let you know the cities that we're
going to alright I don't even know if
you know for sure I'm somewhat somewhat
ill informed yeah okay so we're going to
New York City that's on October 10th if
that makes sense going to Washington
Washington DC and then you're taking two
days off to go to a friend's wedding
correct and I am gonna be doing other
things I'll be in North Carolina and
Atlanta and then we're going to be
together in Orlando at Hanks High School
Auditorium serious I'm dead serious then
we're gonna be you're gonna make me very
uncomfortable st. Louis they've improved
the auditorium a lot since you were a
student there Naperville Illinois or
possibly Chicago not totally sure st.
Paul Minnesota oh one of the Twin Cities
Missoula Montana Spokane Washington
Bellingham Washington Portland Oregon
and Corte Madera California which I
think is in the San Francisco area and
lastly I think somewhere in the in Los
with some more Los Angeles II sure and
that is the tour that's the tour I
apologize
everybody who's like but I don't live in
any of those places well like neither do
most people let's be honest in fact
almost all humans don't live in any of
those places but if you do live in one
of those places please come visit us on
tour tickets are on sale now I think and
you can find out more somewhere on the
web I'm not totally positive we're good
this was a great promo John and I should
do this for a living it's really about
having all the information at your
fingertips John there's a Twitter
hashtag going around right now and it's
ruined a book change letter change a
letter ruined right something like that
yep so you could you could date where
we're when we were recording this by
that information but I was trying to
come up with one for turtles and all I
got was Turtles al the way down would be
like a book about a guy named turtles al
who like runs a turtle store but it's
it's like it's the story of his of his
like inevitable decline it's good I like
turtles all the way Mon which is about
an evil person who mows over Turtles
with his lawn mower that's really good
that's better that's better I like that
one better than mine okay all right so
come visit us on tour if you have the
chance we're very excited about it and
with that noted Hank how are you I'm
good I'm good that's all I had was that
thing about the about the thing and I oh
I'm glad you prepared that bit that was
very solid yeah I'm going to Australia
so I haven't been able to think about
anything except all the work I have to
do before I have to go to Australia well
let me take a little bit of workload off
of you by asking the first question from
our listeners I alright alright this one
comes from Karen who writes dear John
and Hank I'm applying for pharmacy
school and some of the supplementary
questions ask me about which of my
personal characteristics makes me unique
how does one even answer this question
is this different from a question about
my unique experiences I'm so confused
frustration and confusion Karen first
off Karen nobody is unique she's yeah
yeah I'm coming in like and that's what
pharmacy school really wants they want a
budget there were not bunch of people
who are I dislike each one
is not at all similar to the others they
want weirdos there at pharmacy school
yeah I'm not sure that I want my
pharmacist to be one of the most
eccentric people on earth like you
imagine Maureen Johnson like preparing
your scrip no I don't want her counting
my medications I love Maureen Johnson
and she is unique and I do not think
that you and I I don't even think that
she would disagree with me about this I
don't think she would be a great
pharmacist all the all of the most
eccentric people I know almost
invariably shouldn't be pharmacists
which isn't to say that I don't love
pharmacists I have a great relationship
with my pharmacists they are all lovely
people by evidence I have a real-life
friend who's a pharmacist and I asked
them once I was like would you prefer if
I come to your pharmacy and they said no
I don't want to know all your stuff John
I don't want yeah don't make it weird
yeah III think that's a dumb question
first off none of your personal
characteristics make you unique secondly
if I'm a pharmacy school I want someone
who's a good student who's organized
who's disciplined who you know is bright
and hard-working
I don't know that I'm really looking for
the further out they're weirdos I like
the idea that there's like a personal
character unique personal characteristic
and it's like look mine doesn't have a
name because it's unique literally no
one has ever had it before right it's
called Scrabble mine's called alga man
and I can't even explain scruple to you
because it is so unique that it is it
does not touch upon any of the previous
understandings you have had about the
experience of what humans are like right
you're not able to access this because
you don't have language for it you can't
have the thoughts that scruffles have
and then in fact that's what you should
do Karen just next to that question just
writes crevel in all capital letters
underline it exclamation point and then
in parentheses explain that you can't
explain this using language that people
who decide whether you get into pharmacy
school have access to like
be that like definitely get their
attention the first letters should be
like the s should be lowercase the K
should be lowercase but the R in the ER
uppercase v is lowercase e in the lr up
case that's how that's how it's that's
how scribbles veld yeah
scruff oh hey can you say anything about
scribble or is it like no it's just like
it does not okay it does not connect
with the norm like with it with the the
broad cultural understanding of humanity
it's just it's it's too disconnected
John
there you go Karen I think we've found a
solution for you that will definitely
not get you into pharmacy school comes
from hope who asks dear Hank and John
what is the plural form of dingus I use
it constantly both affectionately and
otherwise and then perplexed is it dinga
dinga says or is it just like deer and
the plural remains the same as the
singular just a bunch of dingus signed a
dingus and need hope hey I don't know
how far you fell down the dingus rabbit
hole while researching this question but
I fell pretty damn far yeah do you first
I felt like one one step down I I just
googled to dingus etymology and that's
as far as I got do you know I know that
it comes from the Dutch do you know what
a dingus is it said the Dutch word for a
well ding is Dutch for a thing right
it's a like it's just a ding but but
like that ding over there I thought a
dingus was like an idiot like oh I'm
being such a dingus about this yeah
that's sort of what I yeah that's kind
of my idea voting that is not what the
dictionaries idea of what a dingus is
the dictionary thinks that a dingus is
like a doohickey or a thingamajig oh
this little dingus here it's like you
know like the word to describe a thing
either because there is no word
associated for it or because you can't
access the word or your vocabulary
doesn't have it or whatever right so
it's like Scrabble it's not it's not
really it's a little bit during from
scruffles in that it is an established
word that wasn't made up four minutes
ago but but yeah that is the initial
meaning of dingus and it's not totally
clear how it came to mean like a dingbat
except that it seems to sort of sound
like a dingbat or you know it sound just
sounds like a dingus it sounds like a
ding you dingus right yeah it sounds
like it should mean what it means which
is a really interesting thing about
words and meaning yeah is that that kind
of happens oh yeah where yeah it isn't
just a one-way street where like we need
a word for this we try and find a word
that sounds like the thing right right
[ __ ] no it's a common item on appiah but
inside your brain so when I fell way
down the rabbit hole I found out
something amazing which is that
doohickey you know a word that I use all
the time when I'm trying to describe
something that I can't remember the name
for doohickey comes from two words that
also meant that doodad and Hickey before
Hickey meant like a bruise that you
would get on your neck from extremely
aggressive kissing Hickey meant the same
thing that doodad and dingus meant which
is to say that we have a lot of words
for thing that we have forgotten the
word for yeah well that's an important
important thing to have a word for and
it's not just a thing you've forgotten
the word for it so I think that doesn't
really have a name like the little thing
that converts my Apple charger from like
an extra-long plug to just the one that
I can store up for easy travel that is
that's totally it that's a dink it's a
singham ABAB yeah it's a what do you
call it it's a duder it's a it's a
gubbins is another word that means the
same thing really yeah good yeah oh man
mister governs that'd be a great name
for a character and a and a and a
children's book it would today is just
today you didn't know this and I didn't
know it either but today's dear Hank and
John is all about etymology and the
relationship between language and
thought it's just I like it okay so uh
dot none of what we said got to the
answer to the question what was the
question I have knowing what is the
plural of dingus oh I'm not sure John I
figured you
the answer because apparently you went
way down the dingus hole so there's an
alternative form of dingus which is
Dinky's and I think that would be a good
player form but according to the
Internet it is not the actual plural
form the actual plural form is dinguses
yeah I figured it might be dinguses but
we had a really good conversation about
dinguses anyway that that that made it
all worthwhile I mean I don't know that
it was worthwhile but I mean you know
you have to use your one wild and
precious life somehow and this is how we
choose to do it before you ask the and
the next question John let me remind
everyone that we have a phrase of the
day week out of the week or whatever and
one of us is gonna try and wedge that
phrase into into the speaking without
without anybody out there in the
listening world knowing that we're doing
it and if we can do that effectively
then we win and I understand that it's
not a good game it's not a well designed
game but we have fun thinking about it
so that's what's important I've
forgotten what the freeze is John we
talked about it I forgot what it is
don't tell me well I'm not gonna tell
you what it is because that would be
cheating yeah you you've gotta you've
got to slide it in there and I don't I
won't even know what happened all right
hey this is a question near and dear to
both of our hearts it comes from Kate
who writes Dear John and Hank staying in
a hotel for almost two weeks on a work
trip has taught me that hotel rooms are
in fact the world's loneliest places
I've been distracting myself in the
evenings by facetiming my boyfriend but
after hanging up the room feels even
quieter and lonelier than before do
other people feel this way when
traveling for business any tips on
making a hotel stay more bearable and
then Hank you will not believe her
sign-off from the lonely abyss of a
Courtyard Marriott Kate the whole story
so in 2012 Hank and I spent with two
exceptions 30 consecutive nights in
courtyard Marriott's so the the
geographical location in which we were
would change nightly but the layout of
the
never changed yeah we would always lay
out of the room it's the the art on the
walls yeah the bedspread yeah the
wallpaper the toilets were all the same
the red loveseat the yeah desk the chair
the bed and I'll tell you what Kate it
did get a little dark after a while yeah
I mean my strategy for solving this
problem is to not go to the room until
it is sleep time and the whole time I'm
in the room be listening to a podcast
because then I don't like just distract
myself from the fact that I'm doing this
hotel room thing the worst trap I feel
like you can fall into is watching TV in
a hotel room because then you're just a
wake forever yeah for some reason I have
a very hard time sleeping once the TV is
on in a hotel room and I just want to
like watch the end of this of this
terrible piece of fake documentary about
the worst air disasters right before I
get on a plane yeah I mean I think so
first off Kate I think this is a common
thing I remember being very excited
about my first work trip and then like
getting on it and being like oh is it
like this all the time and now 15 years
later it is like that all the time now
sometimes I you know there are
advantages to it like I can sleep in at
least sometimes which I can't do when
I'm sleeping at home because I have
little kids and that can be nice and
that's an upside that I can look forward
to another upside that I can look
forward to is that sometimes I will like
happen across a movie on HBO if they
have HBO in the hotel and I'll be like
oh I can watch a movie but I agree with
Hank that like watching sort of like
endless linear cable TV is not a recipe
for good sleep so I think it's good to
listen to podcasts I think it's good to
watch movies I think it's great to read
a book I usually try to read when I'm in
a hotel room but it's hard to sleep in
those places at least for me and yeah
work travel that I always thought was
gonna be like you know I can't believe
that they're paying for my hotel room
occasionally I'll think that when it's a
very nice hotel room but most of the
time I think like oh that's another it's
another hotel room this place probably
has bedbugs it's all probabilities John
I mean I would not want to see a black
light in any of those rooms agreed all
right John next question it comes from
Brianna who asks dear brothers green
I've recently started working on a
cruise line and one of my first days at
sea I saw a thunderstorm off in the
distance and it got me thinking waters
good conductor of electricity right so
when lightning strikes the ocean how far
does the electricity spread and for how
long does the affected area stay
electrified is it possible that my ship
could be electrocuted from the storm off
near the horizon thank you for either
quashing or amplifying my fears Brianna
can you get a podcast on a ship oh of
course you can they have wireless now
Brianna I've got good news and bad news
the bad news is that you're going to die
of norovirus on that ship so it doesn't
really matter that you're not going to
die of electrocution from a lightning
strike I mean of the things that could
kill you on a ship I would say that
norovirus is the is the bigger concern I
I have a bunch of information on this
John
if you're curious I'm very very kind of
a weird fact which is that the lightning
lightning very rarely strikes the ocean
mmm that's interesting
why yeah because for a couple of reasons
one there's not really like like
lightning likes to go to a place and
when it's just this like infinite flat
plane it just strikes internally inside
of the cloud so if it's above the ocean
it tends to be cloud-to-cloud lightning
more than cloud-to-ground lightning
second because it seems like lightning
actually happens when the kind of
perturbations that the land tends to
create which is like a lot more heat
comes off of land and there are also you
know actual physical boundaries that can
make clouds bump around and move around
the that lightning tends to happen when
those kinds of obstructions start making
all the
of the stuff rub together more than it
was previously but it does happen it
does strike the let the ocean sometimes
and enough that we know a little bit
about what happens when lightning
strikes the ocean which is because to be
first of all water is not a great
conductor of electricity but saltwater
is so what happens is it goes into the
water and then it spreads out very
quickly until you know not very far away
from the point of the lightning strike
it is not a significant amount of charge
if you're sitting right there where the
lightning strikes you're gonna die but
but it does not go very far and so it
probably it doesn't kill very many fish
for example did I ever tell you about
the time as you know Hank I have a
long-term fear of dying via lightning
strike because I grew up in Orlando
Florida and also because I have you know
a number of the major death fears did I
ever tell you about the time that I
walked away from the wedding what are
you talking about now okay so one of
Sarah's family members was getting
married it's a bit of a shotgun wedding
we were on top of a mountain in Colorado
and it began to like rain and
thunderstorm and there was lightning
strikes everywhere and everyone was
holding umbrellas on top of a mountain
and I was like this is it this is how
we're all gonna go and the bride and
groom were like it's okay we're gonna
get married in the rain and I was like
y'all can do whatever you want but this
is not how I died and so I walked away
also I gotta have to congratulate you on
seamlessly including the phrase of the
week shotgun wedding in your little
anecdote John I know it wasn't a shotgun
wedding they had been dating for like
ten years but so I just I just
fictionalized that one detail so that I
could get the story and thank you Hank I
think that I I think that I win the
prize you definitely won that we
definitely won this week I I was
thinking maybe I was gonna get the
lyrics to Beck's loser somehow
the podcast but yeah it's too late for
me now
I mean well that like yes and I agree
what I honestly agree with you because
it's not like it's one thing if somebody
get struck by lightning and they die
it's another thing if like the entire
family goes like everybody's there one
lightning strike it could be like ah
like the line has ended remember that
remember that Jefferson's they are no
more right no I work on the Soul
Survivor reading it's like that TV show
or Kiefer Sutherland becomes the
president okay we've got another
question this one's from Lilly honor who
writes Dear John and Hank hey this is
one of those questions sometimes I feel
like people send us in questions and
what they really need is not advice or
answers what they really need is
reassurance that they are doing exactly
the right thing okay and I think that
Liliana is in such a situation she
writes dear John and Hannah I'm 15 and
I'll be a sophomore in high school next
year
over the summer I've been asked over and
over again by relatives and family
friends all adults if I know where I
want to go to college and what I want to
study I have no idea so my default
answer has just been to say fish and art
before walking away what am I supposed
to say to this question definitely fish
and art yeah I mean you really are good
but you've cried you hit it you've
cracked a code that's haunted high
school sophomores for hundreds of years
Oh Mike why are you asking a high school
sophomore anything about college ah
and then they say wait is fish an art
what you want to study or where you want
to go to university you just say fish
fish and art and art fish and art I'm
going to the University of fish where
I'm going to study art and fish that's
going to the University of art and I'm
gonna be studying fish horticulture I
apologize ESCA culture if my answer was
ambiguous but uh or perhaps I said
let me just repeat myself dish and art
ask me again
uncle ask me also Liliana I'd like to
encourage you to actually study fish and
art oh yeah
either you know that could mean a lot of
different things like fish could be
biology like wildlife biology it could
be the dream ecology it could also be
like actual agriculture like fish
farming which is a growing industry and
one that is in need of great people to
be managing fish farms and art of course
can mean pretty much anything so it's
good to have a diverse group of
knowledge like it's good to mix a
creative degree like art with a
potentially a degree that has like
available jobs and that you'll develop
marketable skills at like fish so yeah
absolutely
ocean art I just want to throw this out
there as an option I also think that she
could consider studying fish and other
jam bands I'm sorry I'm sorry
jimp is just jammed into the phrase of
the week was that seem really really
wedge did oh I mean fish is one of the
leading jam bands thank you I've got
knowledge Liliana clearly spelled it
with an F and and she's at evening she
might not know how to how to spell fish
yet I'm going to college to study the
band fish I uh oh I guarantee you that
there are many many people who have
written their undergraduate theses on
the band fish I when I was a freshman in
and in college I listened to Trey
Parker's to senior thesis from his
school which was a musical like a rock
musical thing and I downloaded it in
real media files and I listened to the
whole thing it's real weird John I
believe it I believe it yeah
but that's where you brought us that's
why you brought us I don't think I took
you there but three Bronto Google PhD
thesis about the band fish not that I
did that and not that I became the first
person ever to Google that particular
search do you know what you learned what
okay do you remember the band The
Offspring aha yeah I'm just a sucker
with no self-esteem no way the lead
singer of The Offspring Dexter Holland
has a PhD in molecular biology from the
University of Southern California he
just got it well just this year actually
really yeah that's great I'm really I'm
very I'm excited for Dexter yeah me too
yeah congratulations to Dexter Holland I
don't know that the band the offspring
and fish have anything in common but I
appreciate Google just trying to reach
out and be broad John this podcast is
brought to you by the molecular biology
degree of Dexter Holland the former
frontman for offspring or maybe current
frontman current frontman for offspring
oh I think he could get it all done all
at the same time
that's right congratulations Dexter
Holland and thanks for thanks for for
being one of my favorite - some of my
favorite songs when I was in high school
this podcast is also brought to you by
the lonely abyss of the Courtyard
Marriott the lonely abyss of the
Courtyard Marriott vast even endless of
course this podcast is additionally
brought to you by Scrabble Scrabble you
don't know what it is and you're never
gonna know what it is because it's a
unique characteristic of my personality
lastly this podcast has really actually
brought to you by our friends at
Squarespace John yes what do you do when
you want there to be a thing on the
internet that's like here's my thing
well we're just going through this now
with me we're just going through this
now with the creation of the tour
website and the sort of new website for
turtles all the way down and of course
we did use Squarespace
because it's just really easy and
straightforward to make a website with
them we use their their services to make
probably Sun turtles calm to make my
author website John Green books because
there is still a purpose to having like
a life outside of the social Internet
online Hank and I've talked about this a
lot we're big believers in having your
own places online if you can if you can
find them and build them and Squarespace
is a great tool for that yeah it used to
be it used to be a lot harder and and
and I remember like making websites for
you John like making your website and
and sort of it being a big deal for for
me till I get the job of making your
website but I still think that it in a
way like that like having like in a way
that is not the case for having a
Twitter or a LinkedIn or whatever having
a website is actually like it's a sign
of commitment to something and it's kind
of like a big deal that you have to
invest some actual time in you know
Squarespace makes it very easy but but
also like to make a good Squarespace
site you do have to think about it you
have to think about what you're going to
put on there what you want it to be and
what you know and and spend some time
building it and making it your own and
it's wonderful that their templates
allow for that I've had a really good
time making my making my Squarespace
site which has not launched yet but it
will and it's what's it about it's just
about Hank green oh oh it's just a
hangry no Tom I thought it was like
something exciting where you were like
building a new product or something or
you were gonna do goodness ecommerce
sales for I don't know nesting dolls I'm
not a nesting dolls business yet I was
gonna say I was I was gonna add the yet
you can go to squarespace.com slash Dear
John to learn more and also to get 10%
off of your first order or you can go to
squarespace.com slash dear Hank but
squarespace.com slash Dear John that's
the one that everybody's using yeah
squarespace.com / dear Hank has a real
nice ring to it though and I think that
it's on the up and up I think it's come
I think it's coming it's cresting the
the way of John I like it's sometimes
it's better to be first like Dear John
is but sometimes it's it's better to be
best like dear Hank
alright well make your next move and
your next website with Squarespace and
thanks again to Squarespace for
sponsoring today's podcast the URL just
one last time is Squarespace calm / Dear
John Hanke
this one comes from Gaby who says dear
green brothers why do I always feel
safer when I turn the lights on when I'm
scared my first instinct is to turn
every light in my house on but logically
I have no clue what I would do if I saw
someone standing there when I turned on
the light reasonably I know that I would
have just like a few extra moments of
terror before getting murdered because I
wouldn't be able to defend myself so why
do I always feel the overwhelming urge
to turn on the lights when I'm scared
how frugal is the chariot that bears the
human soul gap so Hank a while ago I
read this really fascinating book called
at day's clothes night in times past
that talked about what night was like
for Europeans before electric lighting
and I think the reason we turn on the
lights
is because night for almost all of human
history
was a very bad dangerous scary time and
lots of bad things could happen to you
and you had very little warning that
they were going to happen so I think
like like from an evolutionary
standpoint night makes us nervous and
from what I could gather from that book
it ought to I mean Gaby what I'm coming
at this from is like I'm not I'm not
turning on the light so I can find the
murderer I'm turning on the light so I
know the murderer is definitely not
there like if I found the murderer it'd
be like this is worse then when the
lights were off like I want the murderer
to or whoever to be on their way and to
do their thing I do not want to have a
face-to-face encounter with a home
intruder have my computers go ahead have
a nice day but I want to know that that
person is not there and that is the only
way to know that they
not there is to turn on all the lights
and it's pretty amazing that we can what
a wonderful moment we live in that's
true I agree a hundred percent the only
thing that I would add is that the other
advantage turning on the lights is that
potentially it makes those who would
rather do their work in private and
unseen suddenly be seen which I don't
even know if that's good or bad I don't
know all I know is that when I read this
book at days cuz it scared the living
crap out of me and also I learned that
in like early modern Europe there was it
was very common to wake up at two
o'clock in the morning for an hour or
two and then go back to sleep
which is the weirdest thing about pre
nineteenth-century life that I've ever
come across
yeah that's when there was like a
special special prayer time and then
also that's when most of the babies got
made yeah and I think maybe a little bit
of like just sort of like let's go walk
in the nice the nice chill of the
evening no there was not a lot of
walking scrub up the pants no some pants
crumpet no I don't know I mean I wasn't
I wasn't there when you read the book
John I just I just heard what the
internet had to say about it okay yeah I
just I I found that time I don't know
I've also been reading a really good
book about 17th century Paris and the
first police chief of Paris Hank that I
have to recommend
I think it's called City of Light city
of poison and uh it is a rip-roaring
adventure that is completely true this
next question comes from Stacey who
writes Dear John and Hank why can't my
bathtub just be in my living room best
fishes Stacey oh wow that's a good sign
off it seems like she's been talking to
Liliana yeah John I once had my bathtub
in my bedroom oh yeah when when we lived
in New York one of our closest friends
had her bathtub in her kitchen and when
when she asked the landlord why is the
bathtub in the kitchen the landward
explained well because all the other
plumbing is here
[Laughter]
it's just yeah I mean like there aren't
any other dis knock their doors in your
apartment like what why is my seven foot
long pipe when I could just buy a 1 foot
long pipe I mean yeah why have it why
have a bathtub at all you've got a sink
ha ha ha ha just crouch in there just
get in there you know what I think you
can't have a bathtub in your living room
and if you own your own home you can
bring in a contractor and say the first
thing that I would like to do when
renovating this house is to put a
bathtub in the dead center of the living
room so that I can watch TV while I
enjoy my luxurious baths and the
contractor will probably say that's not
gonna be great for resale value and then
you tell them that you want to do it
anyway this is my house I wouldn't
Katherine and I were looking for houses
we did happen upon a home that had in
the bedroom
a giant jacuzzi tub that had clearly
been put in by those owners out and the
bathroom was there the bathroom was was
like you could reach the bathroom door
from the jacuzzi tub I was like why did
you just make the wall go out around no
that's nice that in your master right up
to the jacuzzi tub and then there was a
step yep that you could step on to get
into the jacuzzi tub that was also
carpeted yes I just this was a very
strange set of decisions and probably
has something to do with the smell
that's in here right no I think that was
a relative in that house I think I was a
relatively common decision back in the
80s Sarah and I also saw a number of
houses that had had that particular
layout and I would think like you know I
love a good bath but I'm not sure that I
want to bathe in the same room in which
I sleep yeah it seems like a recipe for
mold yeah the only reason that it might
my apartment like was like that it when
I first moved to Montana was because
clearly they did not have space for a
shower so they put it in the bedroom
that said Hank did you make any
decisions when you were renovating your
house that you knew were bad for resale
value but you made because they bring
you
personal joy yeah I must have the one
that I did was that I made a secret room
in my house which was stupid from the
perspective of how much money can you
spend on a door
turns out oh ma but it was brilliant
from the perspective of every time I
walk into my secret room I feel as if
for the first time
overwhelmed by childlike joy do you have
like is it just like a bunch of like
like military equipment like Batman it's
just like your your bat car and or is it
just like a bunch of pens and
typewriters or something like you're my
secret identity as I am I am the guy who
writes those books that you've read no
and I come back over there and you put
on it put on a cape and then you know
actually it's actually the room it's
kind of like a work room it's the room
in which I make vlog brothers videos but
it's also kind of a work room but if you
walk up to the door it looks like a
bookcase and then there's one particular
book that if you tap it the bookcase
opens and oh yeah
it is pretty cool I mean I'll tell you
what no one but me would enjoy it as
much as I enjoy it but it brings me
great joy every day oh yeah I have one
the thing that I did that's terrible for
resale value is that we we we have
spruce floors which is just a terrible
idea because it is very soft wood but I
think it's beautiful when I love it so
much
well there you go I think I think you've
got to live your own life and if you
want a bathtub in your living room then
do it man make it happen
yeah mine super boring it's the kind of
wood we chose for the flat is pretty
boring it was actually it was already
there that was there was carpet over it
and the contractor was like this is just
gonna get all dented up and I was like
yeah with my life every dent is gonna be
another thing that happened in my home
get out of here I think that's that's
actually quite a beautiful idea Hank
that over time the floors will change
because you have lived with them I I
quite like that this next question comes
from Clara or if I've learned anything
in the last few weeks possibly Clara or
Clara all I know is that I'm definitely
mispronouncing at Dear John and Hank why
our story problems in math books so
bizarre I've had some weird ones like a
boy who wanted to make dodecahedron
shaped cookies as a romantic gesture for
his girlfriend and the one where a boy
was driving near Umatilla saw a circular
irrigation pipe that was 450 feet long
from his car and wanted to know the area
of it also why do people in math books
not have Google to measure the height of
the Statue of Liberty so as to prevent
height induced nosebleeds most people
would just you know google it I honestly
do not I do not know and I find word
problems very frustrating because it is
as if someone said no we need to find
real-life ways to apply this knowledge
to the world and then it was like well
let's come up with the weirdest most
contrived real-life ways that we could
possibly think of that are just so
outside of anyone's experience that they
might as well be scrapped right if the
idea is that like oh you do use math in
your everyday life then you're gonna be
like but I'm never gonna go to Umatilla
so it's this is irrelevant to me I've
always thought I've always thought it
was because like it's a way of trying to
like imprint the ideas by making the
examples so weird and obscure that you
like you use the weirdness of the ideas
as part of understanding the solution
but I truly don't know and it has it I
remember it's striking me as very weird
when I was like a middle school and high
school student and I'm sure her based on
Clara's experience that things have not
gotten more normal I mean yeah I did
that one math video on vlogbrothers once
upon a time and I had some word problems
at the end of it and I I did choose to
make them as weird as possible but I
also tried to make them very
life-and-death like not my grade well I
wonder what the circumference of that
irrigation
pipe is more like yeah like that there's
like you are going to die if you cannot
solve this math problem right quick
that's definitely the way to approach it
I mean people need to understand that
when you use math in your daily life
it's in an in an attempt to avoid being
eaten by a bear yeah which is really
that like in some ways it actually like
when I use math in my everyday life it's
almost always statistically and it is
almost always pretty important to my
life yes like I think that understanding
statistics is very important to business
and to but also to like making sound
decisions financially and and for your
family's assessment yeah absolutely
I would very much like to see more
statistics taught earlier on I just
think that people are often like well
well
statistics isn't worth teaching if we
can't get into the nitty gritties and
I'm like it's so is and we should yeah
maybe one of our math teacher listeners
will be able to explain word problems to
us in the meantime Hank we need to get
to some name specific sign offs because
we got some great without side my
favorite of the week came in from Sarah
who wrote that she signs off her emails
by saying que sera sera good real good
well I let me get one now this person's
name is Qian who says my name is Pacific
sign off only if you realize that CIA N
is pronounced key and a lock is what you
put a key is pretty great and Emma wrote
in with a number of really good number
specific sign offs including get busy
living or get busy comma Ryan did this
next one makes me really wish that I had
named my son Harry so that he could have
his sign offs you're a wizard and I like
also she has one for Adam it's not a
bridge
it's comma Adam and she signs off her
own email by writing I've been faced
with a real dill comma Emma
dilemma its there there for me I got it
yeah yeah it works especially because
maybe you could be faced with a real
jail just like a pickle like a real real
big yeah yeah also we have to just share
one correction because Hank got
something wrong again and it makes me so
happy when he gets things wrong he got
two things wrong first off Amanda wrote
in to say that in many places it is not
actually legal to pick up a rock and no
that's not a Robert you don't own it and
Kelly wrote in to say Dear John and Hank
I am the on-site manager of a homeowners
association and I would just like to
pause right here and say Kelly there are
some people who are doing the Lord's
work and there are some people who are
doing the Lord's work and you are the
second kind oh my god let us pause to
give thanks for Kelly and all on-site
manager of homeowners associations
everywhere I felt the need to write it
on the topic from last week regarding
whether or not it is okay to deposit
your dogs poop into a neighbor's trash
can given the number of complaints I've
received from homeowners regarding this
very issue I can assure you that the
answer is a very strong no it is not
okay I mean why are these people going
through their own trash well how do you
even know that it happened I mean I
don't understand how you know it like
it's the trash at that point it's trash
the only person who's gonna deal with it
after this point is the person who puts
it in the back of the garbage truck if
anyone's gonna complain it should be
them I think the bigger issue is if
there's a hole or if the bag breaks then
you've potentially got poop in the
bottom of your trashcan bin forever and
you've got to clean it out she went into
a great detail and made a compelling
argument and also if we could make life
easier for the on-site managers of
homeowners associations worldwide please
let us do that because I have been to
many a homeowners association meeting
and I have never felt that kind of
despair anywhere else yeah I have also
and it is
grin some people are good at it some
people can take that on and do it well
and I'm sure that Kelly is one of those
people but I am NOT Hank we're recording
this well in advance so it's gonna be a
little difficult for us to do the Mars
and Wimbledon news but we're gonna
persevere by a bold new segment in which
we predict what the news from Mars
and/or Wimbledon will be eleven days
from now
all right what do you got okay Hank AFC
Wimbledon in a really stunning turn of
events played two games over the last
nine days they played Portsmouth and
Blackpool and this is gonna surprise you
but they won both games six points from
two games beating Blackpool to one with
a last-second
winner from substitute while Taylor the
Messi for Montserrat the Montserrat II
and Cristiano Ronaldo some column and
then up against Portsmouth one of the
biggest teams in Ligue 1 a fan owned
club like AFC Wimbledon Wimbledon won
three nil three nil victory for AFC
Wimbledon in my hypothetical future
against Portsmouth I mean I guess I
guess you're trying to maybe like get
some accuracy out of this but why didn't
you just make it 5:16 you know what
happens you're right
I apologize while Taylor scored a
hat-trick and AFC Wimbledon beat
Portsmouth by five goals they beat they
won eight to three oh man this
goalkeepers need to get there their goal
keeping hands on that oh no our
goalkeeper stopped forty-seven shot okay
good good Wow I think there is another
problem then what will happen in Mars in
Mars news 11 days from now if I have
know anything from googling Mars news
every week it's that someone will feel
as if they have seen something in a
picture from the surface of Mars that
either confirms the existence of aliens
or confirms that nASA has not in fact
gone to Mars and that it's all on a
soundstage and that that is a gum
wrapper isn't it
[Laughter]
so I can confidently predict that there
will be a story of that kind published
somewhere on the Internet 11 days from
Hank I don't think that's I'm gonna
encourage you to be bolder and go ahead
and make a prediction that flat Mars ism
is going to spread through right weather
wildfire well what do you think that
flat-earthers think that Mars is a
planet I also think that Mars is flat
dothey it's uh I don't know of course I
don't know I don't pay any attention to
flat earthers I believe that flat
earthers are 90% trolls and 10% very
confused even then even the 10% like
they're trolls they just have
internalized it so deeply that they
forgot they were once trolls but yes I'm
sure that they think Mars is a
coin-flipping out there and that they'll
do no no no right else all the way down
yeah it's Turtles all the way down man I
I am right now on the Flat Earth Society
discussion boards for the question is
Mars Venus mercury etc flat - it's one
of the leading topics of recent
conversation on the Flat Earth
discussion boards yep um because the the
first comment which is very compelling
is they look round through a telescope
anyway question mark and then the first
reply is their round just like the earth
because I believe that flat earthers
believed that the earth is round but
just not right spherical circle circular
circular but not spherical yeah yeah I
mean I feel like I did we need to read
this entire this entire thread it's been
this conversation has been going on
since 2010 but it is recently updated I
like the person who recently wrote look
no one is claiming that other celestial
bodies are flat
[Applause]
come on does don't don't make us look
like idiots here of course Mars is
spherical well I mean that there was a
reply to that to that one that says each
and every one of the heavenly bodies has
the shape of a disk there are no
spherical planets and then a lot of
references oh yeah oh my god oh I'm on
that loading the including the
impossibility of a spherically shaped
Sun oh man oh god oh man okay I have to
actually you know what that's that's it
that's it that III hit the limit I'm off
I'm out Flat Earth is I could not handle
flat Sunnism I can't I can't I mean I
think there's a place for all kinds of
opinions on the internet but flat Sun it
is flat Sunnism is where I draw the line
sir all right John so aside from the
futility of that jaunt down the Google
hole what did we learn today I I mean I
feel like I just unlearned so much well
we learned that there are a lot of words
for dingus doohickey and thingamajig and
we learned that Hickey is not just that
that suck bruise it's also it's also
apparently a thing that the little dude
er the doodad dingus
we learned that Dexter Holland has a PhD
in microbiology I thought that he has a
PhD yes oh man that's you know well you
know at least me I mean while I was
reading that man I agree I did that was
a [ __ ] teeth great is dr. Dexter
Holland of the offspring oh that's
that's wonderful and lastly we learned
that pharmacy schools are really out to
get those most unique of candidates
there is no such thing as being more or
less unique if you are unique you're
unique it's a personal
I I should have let that go but I did it
and I just and now I have to apologize
for not letting it go okay thank you for
potting with me Hank
I don't know how unique works I don't
know how pharmacy schools work either
it's been a pleasure if you want to
email us you can do so at Hank and John
at gmail.com we're also on Twitter I'm
John Green Hank as Hank green this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson it's edited by
nicholas jenkins our community manager
is victoria bon giorno you can find uh
dear Hank and John on patreon where you
can get our special weekly short podcast
called this week in Ryan's where we
discuss one famous Ryan throughout
history who usually isn't actually named
Ryan the steam music that you are
hearing right now is from the great
gunnarolla you can find him on YouTube
that youtube.com slash gunnarolla and as
they say in our hometown don't forget da
awesome
[Music]